اقوى اقتصاد في العالم بعد
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية. عن
جزيرة تايوان بانها اخطر مكان
على وجه الارض لما تمثله من
العالم بعد من وحل جائحة كورونا.
فكيف لو تم فرض عقوبات على الصين
الغرب الاف العقوبات على روسيا
بسبب الحرب على اوكرانيا. ارتفعت
يحتل المركز الثاني والعشرين
عالميا. وهي مرتبة لربما يعلمها
نسب التضخم. واضرت بالامن
الغذائي العالمي. في وقت لم يخرج
سيناريو اخر فيما لو تدخلت
امريكا عسكريا ضد الصين في
تايوان هذه المرة. هناك ستندلع
الحرب العالمية الثالثة. فرض
معضلة كبيرة للصين والولايات
المتحدة معا. بينما يرى الصينيون
ان قضية تايوان هي اكبر قنبلة
خامدة في العالم فالى اين المفر?
وهذا ما يجعلها رقما صعبا في
الاقتصاد اما الصين فهي صاحبة
حرب اقتصادية وسياسية وعقوبات
وضغوطات على بكين. ولكن هناك
والامريكي والعالمي. الغرب سيتحد
مع الامريكان لعزل الصين. وبدأ
الصين تايوان وتدخلت امريكا.
هناك سيتضرر الاقتصاد الصيني
ازمات القرن الحادي والعشرين ان
لم تكن الاكبر. بريطانيا تصف
البعض اول مرة. برغم العزلة
الدبلوماسية لتايبييه. لكن
اي صراع نتحدث انه صراع عظماء
الاقتصاد العالمي. فيما لو غزت
الاراضي التي تعتبرها الصين
خطوطا حمراء. مع تحذير لامريكا
واشنطن تستثمر اكثر من اربعين
مليار دولار سنويا في الجزيرة.
اليها. او على الاقل عدم
استقلالها. الاقتصاد التيواني
بسبب تايوان? ماذا للعالم.
بالتأكيد سنكون امام احدى اكبر
وتدهور سمعتها عالميا. جابت
القوات الصينية مياه تايوان
الاقليمية واجوائها. فيما لو
دخلت قوات بكين اراضي تايوان.
يعتمدون على المظلة الامنية
امريكية سواء في اوروبا او شرق
ان تدخلت فالعواقب ستكون اضعاف
ما احدثه التدخل الروسي في
اوكرانيا. الغربية لن تجعلها
تتردد بارسال ما يضمن ضم تايوانا
جوية. اختراق للاجواء. الوضع
مكهرب للغاية. والحرب اقرب من
الحرب ستحدث عما قريب. فيما لو
قامت الحرب وتدخلت امريكا ستكون
قليلة فقط حلق هذا العدد من
الطائرات نهاية العام الفين
اسيا او الخليج العربي خاصة بعد
فشل امريكا في حماية اوكرانيا
لو الصين تجهز وتعد الاسلحة ولا
تريد لاحد ان يتدخل. متوقعة ان
بالعتاد والاسلحة. سنكمل المهمة
التاريخية. قالها الرئيس الصيني.
القوة المهيمنة في اسيا. وهو ما
سيهز ثقة حلفاء واشنطن الذين
قوتين نوويتين. بل لتبعات ذلك
على الاقتصاد العالمي. فيما لو
الامريكية وهيمنتها الدبلوماسية
والسياسية. تايوان تبعد عن الصين
الصمود امام الهجوم الصيني. فان
الصين سوف تصبح بين عشية وضحاها.
الحرب ليس فقط بسبب اراقة الدماء
في تايوان وخطر التصعيد بين
يا ترد الصين سريعا. لا مجال
للتهاون في امور تتعلق بسيادة
الصين وامريكا. الولايات المتحدة
ليست ملزمة بمعاهدة للدفاع عن
فشل الاسطول السابع لامريكا
الموجود في جنوب شرق اسيا في
مائة وخمسون طائرة عسكرية في
الاجواء التايوانية. خلال اسابيع
بالنار وسنتدخل عسكريا لحماية
الجزيرة التايوانية. اانت متأكد
الصين ووحدة اراضيها. وانتم من
تلعبون بالنار ايها الامريكان.
وواحد وعشرين. التنين الصيني لا
يتراجع بل يزيد من تقدمه. فيما
السرب. اليس هنالك بديل. ايها
التنين الصيني الرئيس الجو بايدن
فلا تتدخل في شؤوننا الداخلية.
تايوان ساحة اخرى للتنافس بين
يشعل الازمة مجددا. وتندلع حرب
التصريحات مرة اخرى. الصين تلعب
تايوان. لكن الهجوم الصيني سيكون
اختبارا للقوة العسكرية
نحو مائتي كيلومتر. تعتبرها
الصين ارضا منشقة وتدعمها امريكا
التجارية بين البلدين تتجه عكس
الاتجاه القديم. تايوان والصين
العسكرية والدبلوماسية. في
السنوات الخمس الماضية تنفذ
عبر مضيق تايوان. لما كل هذا
ايها كان. بكين تكثف الضغوطات
الصيني. تايوان ارض صينية.
فليعلم القاصي والداني على هذه
تايوان. لم يمضي وقت طويل على
اطلاق وزير الدفاع الصيني لهذه
الادارة الامريكية تتعهد بالتدخل
عسكريا اذا ما قررت الصين غزوة
استعادة تايوان بالطرق السلمية.
لكننا لن نتردد بشن حرب لاستعادة
الصينيين من اللعب بالنار. فهل
تقف بكين عند تهديدات واشنطن
الفين وثمانية عشر. الولايات
المتحدة تدفع بسفينتين حربيتين
تدريبات جوية وبحرية حول
الجزيرة. مناورات برية. طلعات
تزيدان من تموضعهما العسكري في
بحر الصين الجنوبي. لكن قبل ذلك
وعجيب للعالم. التحضير للحرب.
حدة التوتر تزداد. الولايات
فماذا لو حصل ذلك فعلا؟ ماذا لو
اجتاحت الصين تايوان ؟ ما الذي
المتحدة الداعمة لتايوان تفرض
عقوبات على الجيش الصيني. الحرب
يجري ابعاد وصلت امريكا عن روسيا
الى الصين يا سادة. الولايات
المتحدة تهدد والصين ترد. بكين
تندد وتتوعد. واشنطن ترد بالمثل.
حينها. قالها الرئيس وهكذا
تقولها حكومته. وهكذا يردد الشعب
المعمورة. لكن بالمقابل امريكا
لا تتوقف عن التهديد ايضا. وتحذر
سيحدث عندها؟ كيف سيكون الوضع في
العالم يومها؟ يا له من موقف صعب
الكلمات. هذه المرة الرئيس
الصيني شي جين بينغ. سنحاول
الجيش سيتحرك مهما كان الثمن
لاحباط المحاولات لفصل جزيرة
السيادة على اراضينا. ومن يتدخل
بشؤوننا الداخلية فلينتظر الحرب
وكيف المصير.